Vladimir Putin has taken more than Ukrainian
sailors captive in the Azov Sea...
his high-stakes military and political maneuvering...
has ensured the "Group of TWENTY" meeting
will be dominated by TWO people.
The Kremlin chief and his US counterpart Donald
Trump...just like last year's G20 when Russian
meddling in US elections overshadowed the
agenda.
The presidents haven't met one-on-one since
their July summit in Helsinki, where Trump's
behavior toward Putin was bizarrely submissive,
leaving huge questions looming in Buenos Aires.
European leaders and his advisers back home
all want to show a united front and that's
really our objective.
It doesn't really matter so much what what
the practical steps are, as long as we can
show a united front because remember Putin's
objective is to sow discord and disunity in
the Western alliance."
Europe's geography dooms it to being caught
in the middle of Moscow and Washington politically.
When tensions flare in those capitals, Brussels
feels the burn.
At the G20, it will be difficult for Europeans
to see their serious concerns on global trade
addressed while navigating other diplomatic
danger zones.
There are so many things going on there that
could cause problems.
I mean you know Xi Jinping will be there.
So it's possible that if there is language
on trade, that Trump will demand that it says
something very negative about China or that
others will want to say something very negative
about protectionism and Trump will insist
that protectionism is good and America is
first.
Don't forget you also have the Saudis there."
As Ian Bond points out, even more political
drama will be ensured by the presence of Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman,
accused of ordering the murder of journalist
Jamal Khashoggi.
Many European leaders have expressed outrage
and scaled back ties but Trump hasn't.
One thing is certain about this G20 -- there
are going to be some awfully awkward photo
ops.